Hello everyone.
Thanks for joining today.
Um, and I hope you're all enjoying the reinvent
sessions.
Um, today, we're gonna have a session on,
um, multi-agent collaboration with
Amazon,
uh, Bedrock Agent Corp for advanced security
operations. OK.
How many of you here from security
operations or security, uh, that
reports to the CISO team?
Anybody here?
OK. So how many of you are
developers here?
OK, good.
How many of you guys used uh Agent
Core so far?
And it's good. Uh, it's a quite good time. OK.
Now, um, this session is mostly focused
on, uh, how to leverage, uh, Agent
Core, uh, to run the security operations
using multi-agents, OK?
Now, uh, I'm, my name is Venkata. I'm
a senior solutions architect. I'm
with AWS a little over 6 years,
and I'm based out of New Jersey, and, uh, I'm
also a specialist in, uh, AML and as
well as resiliency.
Today I was joined by my colleague Eric.
Hi, I'm Eric Hortzen. I'm a solutions architect
based out of Atlanta and a
specialist in,
uh, machine learning and agentic
solutions,
and I'm gonna be walking
through the code demo today,
yeah. So we're gonna,
today, we're gonna present,
uh,
what is the challenge that we are trying to solve in the security
operations, OK?
And how we are going to leverorage Agent Core
and a little overview on, uh, Agent Core,
uh, Bedrock Agent Corps.
And then we're gonna talk about the solution that we want
to, uh, deploy,
and we want to, uh, run the security
operations. And
we're gonna followed by a core talk, uh,
which, uh, Eric is gonna walk through you through
the code.
And we want to make it more interactive, so feel free
to ask me, uh, any questions, and we'll be happy to
address that, OK?
And there will be a demo after the core doc as well, OK?
Now, uh, some of you are coming from the security
background and some of you coming from the, uh, developers's
background, uh, when you raised hands,
uh, as a solution architect, I worked with
day to day with multiple customers, um,
across the organization and then
sort of my organization as well.
So when we, uh, work with the customers,
uh, I mainly,
uh, ask the question with the customers, what are the
things that
they focus on, and they always
tell me two things. One, a strategic, and
they always look for the operationals.
When it comes to operational specifically for
security, um,
when I interact with the security team, they always say that
we always work on the repeat 2 task.
So, when I did a deep dive on that, what
do you mean by repeated 2 tasks, they're gonna talk about,
we do get a lot of alerts from different security
services that we use,
OK. And we spend a lot of time
on reviewing those or investigating
those security alerts,
and they work on the remediations and
they're gonna summarize it and they're gonna send an
email to the entire leadership of the
organization that they report.
So those are the repetitive tasks, uh,
and
it is
based on the, not a specific use case
or a specific environment, it's every
organization that I have this insight.
Now, most of the time, they, uh,
they spent on the manual work. So they have to do
the investigation,
they have to remediate it, and then they have to send
the report.
And that becomes a complex, uh, and
operational burden, OK?
And these teams are more focused on the operational
rather than on the strategic initiatives, OK?
If it is a task is repetitive, we want to
automate it
and we want to leverage the agents here, and that's why
we want to leverage,
uh, agent, multi-agents in
security operations today, OK.
Now, how do we do that? OK.
Now, If you
look at it, we have 3 steps
that we follow when we get an alert from the other
security team. So can anybody tell here?
So when you get on a security alert, what exactly
do you guys do? Can you describe in three steps
anybody in the room?
We start with
investigation, OK?
We start with the investigation, OK?
What is the alert is about,
how it is impacting, OK?
And then we'll go to the second step where we want
to do a remediation, OK?
There are two steps of remediation. The first one is
we want to tactical, which we want to fix it immediately
so that it won't impact the entire environment.
The second step is we want to fix it for long
term as well, OK?
If that, we should not see that alert again and
again, right?
So there are two steps that we follow. That's the second step.
The 3rd 1 is
we want to do a,
uh, we call it as RCA,
but we, we want to do an entire end to end report
when the alert came and what did we do and
how did we fix it, OK?
So those are the common 3 steps that we see in a
workflow for security operations, right?
Now, if you look at those 3
steps, and they are repetitive, for
any alert, it's a repetitive process
actually. There's no change, OK?
Primarily, we're gonna leverage those 3 steps
to build 3 different agents
to work for us to do this work, OK?
The security operations work, OK.
Now, for that, we're gonna leverage
Amazon Bedrock agent core, OK?
Platform is fully managed, uh, which
gives you flexibility to build,
deploy,
and run the multi-agents, uh,
in a secure way, OK.
Now, within the agent core, you have the
runtime where
you can build the agents using
multiple models and as well as,
uh, different frameworks like lang chain, Lang fuse,
and QAI, OK? That's the agent frameworks
that you can bring in and
We also have AWS strands, SDK,
this agents framework
that you can use to build the agents, OK?
Now,
as an agent, that's the runtime that we're gonna build
it and we're gonna run that agent in the runtime
itself, OK? Um, agent code.
Now, similar to the humans,
agents also requires certain memory capabilities,
certain access to the internal systems.
To analyze the events, OK.
For that, we have agent core gateway,
which will help you to connect to the different tools like
humans. When we get an alert, we'll
connect to some CMDB database to identify
the details, what, what kind of server it is,
and how is it impacting,
and when should I patch that server,
and what is the patching schedule. Everything resides in a CMDB,
OK? So as a human, I'll just log
into the CMDB and identify that. Similarly, agent
needs to have similar capabilities.
To log into the CMDB, identify the details,
and create an, uh, impact analysis report.
So based on the alert, OK?
So, we need to use the same capabilities to the agent
to uh to work uh as
a human,
uh, for, for this workflow, OK?
Similarly, we have, um,
Agent core browser, which will
give you an interactions with the browser interactions. OK,
right now we're not using it, but
uh we also have agent core identity.
In order to connect to the internal systems,
you have a username and password. Similarly, you
want to control when the agent is trying to
gather the details from internal systems. Uh,
we need to provide some kind of authentication mechanism, an
authorization mechanism
so that we can control what agent can see
and what agent can use,
OK? Uh, at the end, we
want to make sure that
what are the actions that are performed by agent, we
want to log it and we want to track it.
That's where agent core observability comes into the picture.
So combining all these components
becomes an agent core platform
which will provide end to end, a single
platform that you can build the agents,
deploy the agents, and run the agents
at scale and securely, OK?
That's where we're gonna elaborate, uh, today
to build, uh, our solution.
Well, Um,
this is the architecture that we are trying to
build today, OK,
uh, to deploy the agents, uh, in
our environment to take care of the security
operations, OK?
This year, if you see on the left side,
um, you have Amazon inspector
and Amazon guard duty. Both are our security
services, which monitor our AWS
services on the network,
and they publish the alerts based on the anomalies
detected in the environment. They're gonna publish the alerts
to the event bridge.
Uh, and then a lambda pick up that
uh event and pass it to the agent
core runtime where
you see an orchestration agent
that is running in the runtime, agent core
runtime, OK?
The orchestration agent is
gonna
send that alert.
To do the investigation.
Remediation and send a report.
It is gonna send that request to 3 different agents
to run
within the runtime,
and those special agents are going to
work with your internal tools
like connecting to your CMDB
connecting to your, uh,
playbooks
to remediate the issue,
OK? The entire team, the
entire, uh, solution is built on agent core
and that works with all the other
existing AWS services, OK?
Now, with that said,
little bit zoom into what
exactly
we do with the agents.
Now, we talked about,
we're leveraging multi-agents to
build that solution, right?
Again, Investigation agent,
whenever we, once we receive the alert, we
want to investigate what is that alert about,
and then we want to work with uh
internal system
to gather the information.
What is the server that is impacted? What is the
software or the OS that is currently running
there? What is the pass schedule? You don't
want to update a server while in the
middle of the production.
You want to understand the um
server nature and the workload that is running on the server,
and based on that, you want to take that action.
Those details.
Everything is residing on the CMDB,
so that investigation agent is going to work
with the CMDB
through agent core gateway,
pull all the information,
and it does the investigation report. It's going to
prepare the entire investigation report, so alert
how it is impacted and what's impacted and what
the schedule looks like
once that is done.
We have the 2nd step, we want to remediate.
Here, we created two agents within the remediation
itself, containment agents, where
one of the agents is gonna prepare a
script for you to build a
As a playbook, basically,
uh, you have a non-production system, some production systems,
and you don't want to operate
by an agent in the production systems in some cases.
For that, we create a playbook. So when the
operator receives an alert, he doesn't have to
go to the internal wiki pages or different notes
what exactly the next step he wants to do.
He, we're gonna build a playbook for him so that he's gonna
follow the steps.
In the second containment agent, which
we call it as executor.
That can automatically remediate the
issue, OK? It is not gonna
create the playbook. It is going to execute the playbook, OK?
It is gonna take the alert,
uh, investigation report, and it's gonna apply the remediation
work. Once everything is done,
that third step, which is the reporting agent
actually. So there was an incident happened, there was
an issue happened, OK.
And you want a summarization report at end to
end. We received an alert at 9 o'clock.
We did this investigation and we fixed
it, and this is the solution that we applied.
End to end, we need a report that we want to
report it to our senior management or we
want to keep it, uh, in our records
so that we can build a context, uh,
end to end going forward, OK?
So this is the 3 different agents that
we are using, and we are going to attach
it to the orchestration agent which is gonna manage all
the agents, OK?
So, Let's
move into the core talk today, OK, so
how do we build this solution? Um, Eric
is gonna cover that. Eric, or to you. All right,
so who here has had to deal with a
remediation investigation of a
security incident incident within your
environment?
So this scenario may sound familiar
to you. Several years ago when I worked
at a large manufacturing company,
I got a call from my sec ops team saying
that my AWS account had been quarantined
because of suspicious activity.
And they had detected that several
extra large instances, EC2 instances,
had been launched in the account in a short period
of time. So,
you know, that's the type of call that is going to ruin
your evening plans or your weekend plans
or whatever you have going on,
um. So we got to work
doing the investigation, doing the forensics
works, trying to find out what user
role profile,
uh, launched these instances, how,
what was the entry point that they
accessed, and I have to admit I do love
the forensics work. It may be a little
bit odd, but I do like going through the logs.
Um, it turns out in that instance
that one of our DevOps engineers
troubleshooting an issue launched a
Jenkins server,
didn't change the default password, left some ports
open to the world, and somebody decided to set up
a Bitcoin mining operation within
our account, and luckily
we caught it and,
and we're able to shut it down. Um,
I'm gonna walk through how
we could do that with Bedrock, uh, Agent
Core without human interference.
So once we receive the alert.
Agents are going to work by themselves and then remediate
the issue as well, OK.
So what are we gonna cover? We're gonna go through
just some basics setting up the agent.
We're gonna set up some tools
that the agent can use. We're gonna create
a security analyst agent first using
strand's agent, and we're gonna
show how to orchestrate multiple agents using
a graph pattern,
um, and then we'll go into how to scale that
agent, so deploying the agent, making
it autonomous,
and then some tips
for making,
uh, for helping the agent.
Follow a more deterministic behavior.
So when we, when we mean by autonomous, uh,
autonomous agent,
basically we're talking about single alert right now
for an, uh, for the demo purpose.
But how do you want to scale it for
different types of alerts and
whenever, and the workflow remains the same and the agent
remains the same, the work remains the same. So we want to
make it more autonomous so that it can make the
decisions, yeah, right.
So first, just to give an intro
to anybody who
is new to agents,
the strands agent loop or an agent loop,
uh, what it does, it takes in the input, so
you can think of this as your prompt, but
it also includes the system prompt
which acts as
the job description for your agent.
It includes the tool specs, so
your agent has tools
to, uh, which are
essentially APIs or, or access
to external systems.
And then there's the actual query and
task that's your prompt,
and then the conversation history uh
for what may have happened uh
previously
that feeds into your agent. It
starts with reasoning, so your large language
model, your LLM
processes that, looks at the tools,
makes a selection on tools, executes
the tool,
the output of the tool feeds
back into that reasoning.
And that loop continues until the agent
decides,
OK, I've completed this task,
and then it gives you the response.
Here we are using astra agents, uh,
in the loop,
uh, the framework, uh, to build the multi-agents.
You can leverage lang chain. You can use crew AI
and you can use, uh, lang fuse as well, OK?
You can use any agent framework
and deploy it to the agent core, yeah.
So just, you know, some basic setup and imports
you can see I'm including strands and I'm
including some MCP tools. I have some utilities
that I've included
uh as well. I'm not gonna go
through those because they're less,
uh,
they are helper functions.
And I want to get into the tools, so.
What are some of the tools that we need?
We talked about maybe having access
to our configuration management database or
CMDB.
We want access to the log files.
We want access to
uh forensics, uh,
data store to store any of the
forensics reports that we do.
And if you've used strands agents, you may
know that you can build, uh, tools
directly within strands agents. So why are we using
Bedrock Agent Core, uh, gateway
for hosting these? It's really to maximize
the reuse. Um, so
we may have multiple agents that need
access to a CMDB tool and
access to logs.
We want to allow all those agents
to, to
access these tools
without having to build them in every, every
agent.
And these, these tools are similar tools that we,
as a human, we use to interact and get
the information to analyze the alerts.
Similarly, we are giving the tools to agent
to, uh, do the, its investigation.
So what is the, what is the gateway?
The gateway provides an interface
between the an MCP interface
model context protocol interface
between the agent and the tools.
So in this case,
I'm going to give the
gateway some permissions.
I'm giving it permissions to
invoke 3 lambda functions
that I've created for this purpose. So one,
you can see the first one is a CMDB
function.
You can see the second one
handles.
Our artifacts and then one that does
notification so sends,
sends emails out.
So I'll need to give the gateway permissions
and once I have that set up,
I'm gonna go ahead and create the gateway.
Um,
what does it take to create a gateway? It takes,
you need a gateway name.
You need the role that we just looked at.
And then you define the protocol
MCP and then I save some
uh output from the gateway
so that we can get into our next step, which is
adding, um.
Adding targets to the gateway.
So what is a target?
Uh, target is that is
the
tool spec, that's the end point
that the gateway
uses.
So in this case that
that consists of two things a lambda function,
the ARN for that lambda function,
and then the tool spec is adjacent
schema defining
the various functions
and operations within that lambda function.
So we can see here
that there's a,
there's a save artifact
operation and uh it takes a
finding ID and a file name.
There's a
list artifacts operation.
And a get artifact operation. So those
are the, those are functions that are defined
in my lambda that interact
with my,
uh, my forensics data store.
So these are the tools that we didn't even go to the agent
sets. We're setting up the tools that agents
can use it.
So this is the first step.
So I've defined the,
I've defined the tool. I've defined the tool
spec. Now I want to add that
target
to my agent,
uh, and so I do that by,
uh, creating a target. I give it a
name. I give it a description.
This is what helps the agent when it's
going through that agent loop know what
tools are available and how to use those tools.
The agents are going to leverage the ALLMs
to select the specific tool based on the alert
that it received. Does it have to contact the
CMDB or doesn't have to contact the CMDB?
It depends upon the alert and the use
case. Yeah,
so go ahead. OK,
so now we have, uh, we have some tools.
I have a,
a
gateway that's,
that's loaded.
Uh, if
suppose in, you know, in any enterprise
environment you're gonna have some, some tools
that run in AWS, you're gonna
have some external tools or some things that are.
Uh, you may have your CMDB
with ServiceNow or, or somewhere else,
uh, and you need a, an easy way to
authenticate to those MCP
servers. So Agent Core
provides Agent Core identity,
which will securely store your,
uh, your credentials and
provide you with, uh,
a way to securely get and generate
and refresh OAth tokens to
access those external services. So that's
what I'm doing here. I'm showing.
I'm getting uh access token to a
gateway that I've,
I've created that has some of the tools
that we have
and
I'm loading those tools in the MCP
server
and we can see here
that it's loaded the CMDB tool,
the forensics artifact tool, and
my notification tool.
Yeah, so all we did is we created the
tools
and we connected the tools to
gent core gateway
and we provided the authentication. That's it.
So for the tools are ready.
Now we are trying to build the agents,
so. All
right. So let's talk about what
agents we might need
for our security operations.
Uh, we'll start with building an agent
that, uh, does investigation to gather
details, you know, that first step in our
process. Uh, and,
in many environments, you can, you already have
run books, you can use your runbook to guide you in
creating the agent through prompts.
Uh, the other thing I'm gonna include here is
Strands comes with
a set of community package tools. One
of those is a use AWS tool.
Uh, and so I'm using that within
this tool,
and what that does, it provides
access to your AWS resources
through the AWSSTK.
So what does the agent consist of?
It consists of a name.
It consists of the tools.
So I've got use AWS. I've got
the tools that we just loaded,
and then it consists of
a system prompt, which, as I mentioned
earlier, is the job description for our agent.
So in this case, the job description is
you're a security analyst,
uh, you'll be given a guard duty finding.
Go and gather details around that and
fill out this report.
And then to help the agent know when
to exit the agent loop, I'm telling
it, stop
your analysis when you have information
you need to complete
the report.
Only fill out, only go and get the details that
are needed for the report
and then save the
completed report and you can see throughout here
I've put in, I've specified the tools
that I wanted to use to help it
execute more efficiently.
This is similar to a human, uh,
security analyst. We're just creating an agent and
assigning that role as a security analyst so
that it can work as a human agent,
yeah. To do the
investigation we're not done to the containment yet
we're just starting with the investigation, yeah,
so here I'll just show you what's in that
uh report template.
Uh, in this case I'm asking
for resource details. I'm
asking for the VPC configuration
and the security groups
uh, in a real life scenario you would probably
ask for
additional, uh, forensics logs
from, from cloud watch from cloud
trail from other
systems.
Um, OK,
so then I wanna run the investigation.
So I need a guard duty finding ID
and I need to load that, uh,
and so let's look at this finding.
Um, this is a finding that I
have
set up in my demo account.
One of my EC2 instances is querying
a domain name,
uh, that's used for nefarious
purposes.
So that's gonna be
part of the payload to my agent that
goes in as the task.
And I will go ahead and
Execute the agent,
so it's going to
Um, It's gonna er.
Um
It will
gather the necessary information. It'll
walk through the tools that it's using
to execute
the operation.
Uh, and, and it'll tell us what it's
doing along the way. So it's getting the instance
details, it's getting the security group details,
it's getting the subnet details,
uh, and it, it compiles all
that into
a report,
um,
which then I can.
Um, is saved in S 3
and I can display that down here. So we have
our, uh, that only took a
few seconds. We can see that it's got a
security operations report,
uh, that includes the details and executive
summary,
um.
All, all, all the sort of things that we
need. So if you look at it, if you
want to employ this one,
in the human loop
or human execution, you have to log into
the different services. You have to log into the EC2 instance
and you have to check there.
You have to go to the cloud trail logs and cloud
watch logs to gather the details.
You have to go to different places to identify exact
location of the resource, and you need to get all, all these
details, but agents.
They do it on behalf of you. So they connect to the
different
resources and they pull that information related to that
alert, and then it's gonna generate that risk
report, OK?
So for that reason, we are creating, we created the
tools, uh, a few minutes
back, yeah,
yeah. We
can see the subnet details
and, and everything that it pulled.
OK, so we've got our first agent. Now what
other agents do we need and how do we orchestrate
them to work together?
Uh, so we talked about having
a containment agent to do remediation.
Uh, in this use case, I've created a containment
helper agent
and a containment actor agent,
uh, and a report agent,
and I'm combining those with in
this case, a simple graph pattern.
The graph pattern is it starts with
investigation which we just saw,
and then.
I have
two branches following
a flow.
So on the right hand side
we allow mutative actions
and that will go to the immediate
containment. So think of your
non-production systems in in my story
earlier that was a
developer environment. There's no problem
in shutting that down
immediately, uh, but you may have
highly sensitive production systems you don't want
your agent
to go and.
Uh, shut down your EC2
instances or block um.
Uh, turn off security,
turn off your roles, uh, block
access to that,
that instance, so you wanna create a containment
script. Uh, so those
are the, the two paths,
and then in both paths we're going to
generate a final report.
So what could go wrong with a use AWS
agent that has access to uh
to do things? How do you control permissions
uh for the agent so that it
can only perform actions
in the location in the environments where
you want it to
perform actions.
For that, we want to use
attribute based uh access
control policies,
uh, and this is what allows an opt-in
pattern
for your environments.
And your resources,
what does that look like?
Uh, so the agent, you create
an agent role policy.
So this is, uh, a policy,
uh, that the
agent uses when it's executing
and it has
under the, uh,
actions you can see it we have it
allowed to do
stop EC2 instances, start EC2
instances, etc.
uh, and it has a condition
and the condition says.
If the
Uh, if it has
this tag,
allow mutative actions by role,
and the tag matches, and I don't give
it a role name, I give it a variable.
Uh, I say it has to match the
actual agent role name.
So then within my EC2 resources,
I say allow mutative actions
by role and I set
the value of that tag to secops
agent.
And within my IAM role,
I also have a tag
that says the agent role name is SEC
ops agent. So if those match,
then the action is allowed. If those
don't match or if that EC2
resource doesn't have.
The tag present, it's not
gonna be able to,
uh, the agent won't be able to perform any mutative
actions against that resource.
So that's the
that's the key of the opt-in pattern
uh as a
as a DevOps engineer, as an engineer,
I have to go and add that tag to
my resource
in order for the agent to be able to act on
it um and so I
can, I can choose to do that or not
do that based on the sensitivity of my system.
Basically we're assigning a role to the agent
and what agent can perform on what
resources actually and then.
This role is based on the tax, and you need
to apply those tax to the resources that you want to,
to be managed by the agent,
OK, so we're agreeing with the fine grain, uh,
uh, permissions because
we don't want to turn one incident into another incident.
So we want to limit what agent can do
and what agent cannot do. So that's why we are
choosing to add that role and assign it to the agent.
All right, so for um
to actually create the graph pattern, let's go
through the steps to do that.
Uh, I'm loading some of the pre-built
agent code that I uh specified
above. We have the investigation agent,
containment,
uh, helper, containment actor, and a
report agent,
and I'm using Strand's graph builder.
So the graph builder
has
really two components. You add nodes,
those are your agents,
and then you add edges, and that's the.
Uh, traverse points between your nodes
so we can see the nodes. I've added
containment investigation report
and then the edges investigation
goes to the containment actor and the
containment helper and I've specified a
condition if and only if allowed
mutative action.
Uh, and that function,
uh, that, that references
a function that I have that goes and
looks at the tags
on the resources and, and
decides
what, uh, to do or tags on the cloud
formation stack,
uh, and, and decides what to do.
I could look in my CMDB database.
It can, it can look in various
places, so that, that's one way to
control some deterministic behavior
in your agents.
And then both go to a report
and then finally
uh we have the set entry point
which will
uh we're setting the entry point as
the investigation
we have some controls to set the max number
of executions and a timeout
and then
we
build, we use a graph builder to build
that and that becomes our orchestration agent,
um. That,
uh, the output of that built command, that's
what we actually call to invoke the orchestrator
so we again can get the findings
from guard duty
and feed that becomes our prompt
and the result of the action
is if we,
if we run this and let it get started
it will,
it will begin investigating
this,
uh.
This incident
and provide a response.
So we added the timeout and we added
the executions number,
making sure that the agent is not going to continuously
loop it by itself.
So we want to exit at some point, OK,
if something goes wrong.
But that'll take
a few moments to run. Here's what,
uh, I ran this
just, uh, just before the session,
uh, to show you the incident response report.
Uh, it gives an executive summary,
affected resources, and then actions
taken,
uh, investigation findings
and containment actions. So in this case I
had it to
perform the actual actions
on my,
uh, on my account.
Uh, it created a forensic snapshot.
It, uh,
isolated the security group.
It, uh, revoked some IAM
permissions,
and it shut down the instance, um,
and, uh, blocked some DNS
communication.
Uh, so it provided, it did the actions and
provided the report all without me having
to, uh,
do any manual work.
OK. So let's
step on to
part two.
We've got some agents. We've got agent orchestration.
Uh, how do we scale these agents?
How do we get them working autonomously
and get them working in production?
So using strands agents or using
bedrock agent core, it's,
it's simple. We can,
uh,
in our agent.
We can decorate the agent with an entry
point, so we have app entry point
and that decorator
goes into the
orchestrator and we can see
here with this pattern I'm actually using
an action pattern in the payload.
So I have two actions. I've defined a
chat action and an orchestrate graph action.
The chat action might
allow a security
analyst specialist.
To actually chat with the agent and ask it
about specific incidents that it's
worked on, uh, and do some
additional research, maybe perform additional actions.
The orchestrate graph agent,
uh, is the automation workflow.
So in the architecture we looked
at earlier,
we have guard duty findings or
Amazon inspector findings. You may have findings
from a third party
system.
That you want to feed into
a lambda function and automatically invoke
your agent.
Well, when you do that, you want the agent to
return immediately.
Uh, you don't want to wait for if it takes
5 minutes, 10 minutes, 15 minutes for it to
do its research and do its its job. You
don't want the,
the lambda running, waiting for that response the whole
time. You want it to
get a payload back
immediately. So that's where asynchronous
invocation comes in,
which is supported by.
Uh,
multiple framework strains agents, bedrock agent
core. So in this pattern,
the
agent, uh, we pass in the payload,
the guard duty finding details to our
agent.
We call, we give it an asynchronous
invoke,
and that will
return a response basically saying I've
started my job. Now what's happening in the
background is the agent continues
to run in the background on Bedrock agent corp.
Uh, and continues to
do the work that it needs to do
to complete the remediation.
Yeah, basically, your orchestration agent
is gonna take care of
the, um, flow, basically, uh, once
you receive the alert, the orchestration
is gonna work with multiple agents,
and
these agents are specialized in the specific
role. They gather the information,
contentment, and create the report
and then pass it back to the orchestration agent,
uh, to summarize everything and then publish
it back.
So we have, uh, we have our agent,
uh, our, our complex agent
now we wanna deploy it to production.
So for that I'm gonna use the Bedrock
Agent C core toolkit.
Uh, it's something that, that you
can download as, as part of the,
um,
SDK or libraries available for Agent
Corre, and it provides
some simple,
um.
Some simple commands.
As a, as a CLI program, so
I can just go through
configure,
uh, and I'm gonna pass in the configuration,
the entry point, so I may have multiple
Python applications within my folder.
I'm, I'm working in the folder that the agent,
uh, exists in
configure, here's the entry point
and it walks through a wizard,
uh,
to build out the configuration for
my agent.
Uh, it'll pick a default name based
on my file.
It will identify that there's a
requirement. Uh, this is built on Python,
so that's the requirements file.
Uh, it gives me the option to do
a direct code deploy or a container
deployment.
I'm gonna choose direct code deploy,
uh, for this use case.
It gives me the option to choose a Python version
and execution role.
Uh, so if you've, if you've
created that role earlier,
uh, you can pass that in here.
And uh give
your agent the access
to do the mutative actions.
S3 bucket is for the
code hosting
authorization configuration. I'm gonna
use uh IM authorization,
which is the default.
The header allow list,
that's for use cases where you want to.
Pass in additional headers if you have
um if you wanna invoke your agent
from third party systems
and and use that OA
token and pass it through so
say you have a user or a system that
already has an authorization token
you wanna pass that through to your MCP
endpoints,
uh, that's where that
header comes into play and then I'm going
to skip setting up memory for that.
So my agent is configured and
then it gives me the next steps here.
I can just simply do agent core launch.
And that will actually deploy my agent
to Bedrock agent cop
in production. It uploads
the code, does all the prep work, so
it makes it very simple
to actually get an agent up and
running and testing and
then of course there's
a few other.
Uh, steps available
to
you. You can
continue on
doing things like invoke.
Uh, you can invoke your agent from that
command line. You can destroy
the agent, uh, to for your
tear down scripts,
uh, so that you're, you're cleaning up. So
it makes it really easy
for you to set up and test your agent in
production and get it, get
it deployed, of course.
Other infrastructures, code patterns
are supported as well, Amazon,
AWS CDK and cloud formation.
All right, so we want some more, we
wanna provide some tips and tricks
on how to get more deterministic behavior
out of your agents. Sometimes if you've built agents,
uh,
it can be challenging to tune
the prompts and get everything
working directly as you want.
Uh, so, a few things that, that
we recommend are one,
within strands, you can use pedantic
models to define structured output
for your agents.
So what does that look like
in the case of the investigation agent?
We have,
uh, we've defined a class based on
the base model,
and I've just given it 33
simple things. Uh, I want a response
message.
I want the list of affected resources
and a severity,
and then I can pass that in when I invoke
the agent. I can pass in
that structured output model.
What that does is suppose
after the investigation.
You have
a service where you want to iterate
through the resources affected
and you wanna perform some
additional logic on those
rather than having to parse
the agent response uh as
plain text, you can, this gives you
a nice object format that you can use.
Another pattern is
to use hooks
within your agent. So
the strange framework provides the
capability to use hooks,
uh, and what this does is suppose
in your.
Uh, use AWS tool.
You have some things that are.
Some things that are tagged as
as production or you have some resources
that you want to make sure
behave in a certain way,
the hooks allow you to interrupt that
tool
execution or uh either
before or after uh interrupt
before the um the
model actually runs to.
Execute in that agent loop
and you can perform additional actions so
you might, you might interrupt when the
tool start
tool, uh,
event calls if you detect
that the use AWS tool is being called
and you detect that the action is
stop EC2 instance
and you want to
add some additional logic there to say, you
know, do this, don't do that,
uh, that's what hooks will
allow you to do.
And then finally you can actually nest
multi-agent patterns.
So we've talked a lot about remediating
EC2 instances, but your environments
aren't made up primarily of
EC2 instances. You may have things
in
ECR, you may have lambda functions, you may have databases
and, and RDS or other systems,
um, so you can create
multiple.
Remediation pattern agents following
your run books
and use those uh
in a multi-agent pattern so you have a
a a graph
that uh takes care of
just lambda functions and that can be a
child graph of your main graph
that does your sec
your full secops workflow.
So, these are the, uh,
QR codes for our services, and
we're gonna post the solution uh soon uh
into our samples, GitHub samples.
And, uh,
from your mobile app, uh, if you can
fill out all the survey, so that would be helpful for
us, OK?
Uh, we are here for the next 10 minutes in the hall.
Uh, if you have any questions, um,
please stop by here and I'll be happy to help. Yes.